>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D. C.
>> Catalina Gomez: Well
to today's program.
I'm Catalina Gomez, a
reference librarian,
in the Hispanic Reading
room here at the library.
It's my pleasure to introduce
today's event and to welcome you
to the Library of Congress on
behalf of the Library of Congress,
Hispanic Division and we
are delighted to collaborate
with the Embassy of Columbia.
We love collaborating with
the embassy and today,
we are going to picture
Claudia Isabel Nava a historian
from Columbia who will be talking
about Francisco de Miranda.
Before we start though, I would like
to just make a few announcements
and also to tell you a little bit
about the Hispanic Reading Room.
So I don't know if any of you
that there's a reading room
in the library devoted
to Hispanic collections,
also [inaudible] Hispanic because
we include Portugal and Brazil.
We are located on the second
floor of this building
and basically the history
of our division,
we are the primary access point to
research related to the Caribbean,
Latin America, Spain and Portugal
and also Latinos in
the United States.
So I hope you all visit us.
We're open from Mondays
to Friday from 8:30 to 5.
And just a few announcements as well
before we move onto the program.
Make sure please that
you silent your phones
for the duration of the lecture.
I also wanted to let you know
that this program is part
of our Hispanic Heritage Month
celebration here at the library
and we have had a lot of
very fun events already
and this is our last week
of events in the library.
Tomorrow we have a lecture at
noon in the Mary Pickford Theater
which is across the street
in the other building.
It's a book talk by Professor
Chrissy Arce from the University
of Miami and the title of the
lecture is "Mexico's nobodies.
The culture legacy of the
soldadera and Afro-Mexican Women".
Now, it's my pleasure to
introduce Gladys San Miguel,
Minister Counselor of
the Embassy of Counselor
who will introduce
our speaker today.
Thank you.
>> Gladys San Miguel:
Well, hello everyone.
On behalf of the Embassy
of Columbia,
I would like to thank
the Library of Congress
for this beautiful partnership
to celebrate the Hispanic Month
and it is my pleasure to
announce a great Columbian.
It is an honor because she has
been working to leave the name
of our country, our
history and our culture,
not only in the U.S.,
but also in Europe.
She has a master degree in
Museum Studies from the Museum
of the Historia Natural in Paris, a
Art History degree in [inaudible],
the School of Art and Institute
of Chicago gave her a scholarship,
which allowed her to continue
her art history studies
and what is beautiful about her
presentation today is she began her
career 20 years ago here in
Washington, D.C. She began
with an art work and with
videos about art history
and how rich is Columbia in
art, culture and bio-diversity.
During these 20 years, she went to
Europe and she continued her studies
and she has been working with the
mayors of Paris and the minister
of defense in Paris to talk
about our independence,
and how these great Latin
Americans, as Francisco de Miranda,
contributed to the dream of freedom.
She is talking today about a person
that not everybody
knows how special he is.
He is Francisco de Miranda,
the only human being to fight
in three different independent wars.
He fought with the United
States along the French
and the Spanish Army
against the British.
Then he fought as a general
in the French Revolution.
He is the only Latin America the
degree of general and then he came
to America to fight for the dream
of freedom, but I won't say anymore.
I will just leave this
great Columbia.
Thank you Library of Congress for
opening this space for our country
and thank you, Claudia
for leaving the name
of Columbia in the highest remarks.
You are a true Columbian,
a great Columbian.
[ Applause ]
>> Claudia Isabel Navas:
Thank you for being here.
Thank you all.
I would like to thank the Minister
counselor, Gladys San Miguel,
for this kind invitation, his
excellency embassy Camilo Reyes.
I would also like to thank very
much Georgette Rum [phonetic]
and her staff, and especially
Catalina Gomez for having carried
through this project
that begun a year ago.
A year ago in 2016,
we celebrated all
over the world the
bicentennial 200th anniversary
of Francisco de Miranda death.
He died in prison in
Spain the 14th of July.
As you all may know, the 14th of
July is the Day of the Bastis,
[phonetic] which is
actually right now passing.
So most biographers of Francisco de
Miranda say he had the revolutionary
elegance of passing away
on the 14th of July.
I have selected a series of images
that would let me kind of get
into the subject as it is a
very, very large subject matter.
As you will find out Francisco
de Miranda had probably 10 lives
in his 66 years of life actually.
As Gladys San Miguel
said, he was the only man
who fought in three revolutions.
So he was here in the U.S. in 1781.
He belonged to the Spanish
Crown Army and he fought
with the Spaniards to the
Port of Pensacola Fort.
That was 1781 and then he went
to France and he became general
of the Army in 1792 and
he made a first expedition
to South America in 1806.
So this is really early timing.
He came alone to South America
with a flag and he tried
to free South America with two
boats and not too many men.
Obviously, it was a
very, very big defeat.
He lost that attempt, but it gave
people the idea of a possible way
of freeing the South America
part of America, South America.
So let me just maybe
begin with who --
introduce a little
bit my own background.
I am art historian.
So many people may ask why is an
art historian working on military
and political men and actually I
came about Francisco de Miranda
through my art history studies
because Francisco de Miranda was one
of the first men as well to
define what human heritage
and human legacy was.
This happened when French General
Napoleon Bonaparte started taking
the art work from Italy into
his museum, the Napoleon Museum,
which later became [inaudible]
Louvre and the Museum of Louvre.
So at the time, Miranda in 1795, he
starts writing political pamphlets
and denouncing the
expatriation of cultural heritage.
So that's how, as an art
historian, I came about working
with Francisco de Miranda and then
it became a much larger project
when Columbian ambassador
in Paris requested a project
on Francisco de Miranda
because we were going
to commemorate the 200th anniversary
of independence in South America.
So Francisco de Miranda was the
person who represented this aspect
for France in any case
and I think for the U.S.,
it's a person who was seen as a one
of the most knowledgeable
people and man of his time.
John Adams wrote in his
memories that if anybody knew
of American independence,
U.S. independence,
the man who knew the best in history
was actually Francisco de Miranda.
He was a very, very well
educated and curious person.
So let me comment on these few
images I have selected for you
to introduce Francisco de Miranda.
Francisco de Miranda
has this portrait
in the Chateau de Versailles.
He was remembered as one
of the generals of the Army
of the north [inaudible].
He has his name [inaudible] as well.
He was there in 1789 actually
right before La Bastis [phonetic]
and then he came back in 1792 and
the frontiers were closed in Paris
at that time and so he
couldn't leave and the generals
of the French Army
asked him to stay.
Here are his peers.
You can see Lafayette.
[Inaudible] was his -- [inaudible],
the third name of the left column,
was the general in
chief and here on down.
So if you ever go to
Paris, you'll see his name.
he's the only Hispanic-American
found in that.
This portrait is a portrait
that was made of him in 1788
and was started a physiognomist
called Lavatar
and when he saw this pencil
drawing -- portrait --
he wrote a very comparing
psychological description
of who Francisco de Miranda was.
And he said, "You are man that
has very many men inside of you.
You have a world inside you.
All the experiences you have
will carry you on through life."
Actually, it did.
This is probably Miranda
here, probably he's 45.
This is 1788.
He was born in 1750, so he's
38 years old at this time,
but Miranda when he left Caracas,
he was 21 years old and he started
to be very curious and the
[inaudible] sort of literature log.
He read [inaudible] and he started
to think about the possibility
of independence for the colony.
So when he came to Madrid,
he became the king's soldier
and he left the Army in 1782,
so at age 32, at 1782 or 1783
and he started to travel and
this where in the United States,
this is where he gets to New Bern.
He starts traveling
through the east coast.
At that time, he's going to
meet all of the founding fathers
of the United States of
America and he's going
to start writing a project
for South America colonist,
thinking that if the British
colonists have been able
to emancipate themselves
and rule themselves,
so could the Spanish
colony in America.
So they he moved to Europe, where
he gets into the whole movement
of the French Revolution and
here he thinks that if he --
I like this portrait because
you could see Miranda.
This is him right here.
You can see in the background --
you can see in the
background South America
and that really means he's
always writing for the continent
and he's always about Columbia.
So what is Columbia to
Francisco de Miranda?
This is the flag that as
been attributed to Miranda.
It dates from 1810.
It represents Columbia.
Columbia was, at that time,
was the figure of America,
like America the continent.
At that time, when
people said "America,"
it was mostly Hispanic America.
It was not the United States.
America I mean was the
largest empire at the time
and so the United States
seemed very small compared
to the rest of the continent.
So a person that would be America,
that wouldn't exist at that time.
It was actually Miranda
who first registered --
so in 1785, he goes to Germany
and he goes to the Library
of [inaudible], where he's
going to -- right here.
This is 1785 and he gets
this registered, right?
We see the date and then
we can his name right here,
Colonel Francisco de Miranda and
they had to write where they came
from and so he writes "America."
So this is pretty interesting
because it dates 1785.
This means Miranda is already
thinking of himself not
as a Spanish subject because people
who were born in South America,
the colonists were Spanish
subjects, but he thought
of himself as an American.
"I am an American."
William Smith, he writes
North America.
William Smith, he is the son-in-law,
the in-law of [inaudible]
and William Smith is going to be
the friend of Francisco de Miranda.
They're going to travel
together for four years.
They're going to visit most
of the courts of Europe,
most of the collections, scientific
collections, art collections.
They are going to study
all the military strategies
of the greatest rulers of
Europe including Yekaterina ,
Catherine the Great
and they're going
to have this friendship that's
going to last for a long, long time.
So we're going to see
later on when I get
into the project how Miranda is
related to Smith, but I wanted just
to point out in this introductory
phase how it is to be able
to call oneself as something and he
defines himself before the hour --
10 years before, even 12 years
before that actually independence
of this continent in South America,
he defines himself as an American,
which is pretty, pretty
interesting as a concept of identity
like how he starts to
identify this whole issue.
I put a picture of
Jefferson, who he also met.
He was an ambassador of the United
States in France at the time
of [inaudible] and Francisco de
Miranda in the Army consulate
of the French people and he is
called "General [foreign language],"
he was called at the time [foreign
language] Francisco de Miranda also.
I wanted to get you a little bit
into the scope of what his life was
and I imagine already
have been sensing how deep
or profound his existence and
how interesting for a country
like Columbia that can be
because he is also the first one
who will call himself "Columbiano."
So not only would he use the
name to define America Columbia
or to define himself an
Americano coming from America
but he will the use the [inaudible]
Columbiano to attract Columbians.
So here is the first document that
he's going to post in the church --
in the Cathedral of Coro -- in his
adventure of 1806 when he tried
to come and liberate by
himself the continent.
He arrives.
He puts on the flag
that he imagined --
so a flag for his country
that he created in his mind
and he claims himself to be the
comandante general del ejercito
Columbiano, the chief commander or
chief general of the Columbian Army
and he's talking to the people,
los pueblos habitantes del
continente Americo Columbiano.
It is really interesting
because has [inaudible].
I mean these are still
Spanish Empire.
These territories are
part of the Spanish Empire
and nobody has claimed them
to be an independent nation.
Nobody has even claimed that
they can be called Columbiano
or Columbo Americano.
So it is a pure invention
of Francisco de Miranda.
Francisco de Miranda is
a very interesting person
because he created this imaginary
land, this imaginary constitution.
He is the first person to write
a constitution or constitutions
for a government of
transition between the Monarchy
and whatever government
is meant to follow.
Of course, the type of government
that Francisco de Miranda is
thinking is very much like the ones
that he has helped put in place.
So that is the Republic
of the United States
and the Republic of France.
And he -- based on his
personal life experiences,
is going to start creating
a constitution and some laws
for this human's territories
that was America
and a continente Columbo America.
I sometimes wonder where
the name Columbia came.
I think Columbia was a term that
he heard here in the United States
when he came to New York.
Columbia was the image of Columbia
and it was an Indian woman,
the iconography like
Asia or Africa or Europe.
Each kingdom in Europe has
their imagery and iconography.
So, for instance, Kings College in
New York became Columbia University
and the district of
Washington is Columbia.
I mean we hear about
Columbia, Columbia,
so Miranda must have
been very much influenced
because if we see the
flag, we see that America
and Columbia are represented
as a native American women
which was actually the iconography
that went along with Columbia
and then maybe the U.S. changed -- -
Columbia stopped needing
America and just became America.
So there has been several
transitions between that word.
The fact of the matter is that we,
in Columbia, are called Columbianos
and that was something that
Miranda very much defended.
Miranda said in his constitution of
the 1800, said, "The people living
in Columbia should be called
Columbianos and not Columbinos
because Columbianos is much more
elegant and it sounds prettier."
So this is how Francisco
de Miranda works.
He's not -- he's a diplomat because
obviously he is going to meet most
of the rulers of the
late 18th century.
He's going to meet everyone.
He's going to read every book,
every single book he can get.
He's going to visit every
single library he can visit,
scientific collections, private
collections, art collections.
He is one of the most
knowledgeable persons of his time.
He knows about law and that's going
to cause him a lot of problems,
but aside of that -- aside of
all this knowledge he's got,
he's got the wisdom and then he has
the power of creating and imagining.
All of what he imagined was then
carried out by people like Bolivar
and [inaudible] and peers like
St. Martin, but, above all,
he's got the power of
imagining a new nation.
Back to the project, this was the
project that we created in 2010.
It was shown at UNESCO in 2012
[inaudible] and we've traveled
with the exhibition throughout
these cities of the world.
It was a project that had many, many
partnerships, Columbian government,
Venezuela government, French
government and Spanish government.
So that's very interesting
because it allowed us to talk
about a singular period of our
history through one person.
I just wrote a quote that I
saw in the building in one
of the beautiful mosaics that
are upstairs and it says,
"The history of the world is
the biography of great men."
I think that's quite interesting
when we're talking about Miranda
because his memories are kept in
the Archive General de la Nación
in Caracas because
that was his will.
Caracas was the city where he was
born and although his homeland,
for him, was America, was Columbia,
the big Columbia was his project
but Caracas is his homeland and
in his testament, in his Will,
he lends the memories that he had.
Sixty-three volumes that were kept
for 100 years away from public
because it contained
so much confidential
and high-level information that none
of it could ever be
seen to the public eye.
So we had access to those memories
in 1927 and they're now online.
They're digital tools.
We found these memories -- a
project that you can download
from the internet and you can
visit, see, discover the life
of this great man,
who was [inaudible].
So we've divided.
We speak in plural because
this project was made
with a highly scientific committee
from Germany, France, Columbia,
Mexico and Spain and Venezuela.
So all content of the internet and
the content of the different panels
that we show, different exhibitions
all are a collective work.
So what I what I wanted to show
you is a little bit of how he came
to arrive to the United States,
which is the core of our talk today,
Francisco de Miranda
and the United States.
Miranda left Caracas in 1771.
You can find all of this
in the internet if you want
to read carefully and learn more
about his life but he arrived
to Paris, where he's going to end up
living in this house, Cuatro Torres.
He's a young man.
he's 21 years old and what
is interesting about his name
as well is that it is the name of
the prison where he's going to die.
He's going to die in the Arsenal
del los Cuatro Torres 10 km away
from Cadíz.
So he arrives in Cadíz and he
comes back at age 62 to die there.
It would be nice to
mention those things.
This is the army that he's going to
join is the Army of Princess and so
at that time, he's looking
to serve the Spanish king
and he will then be
promoted at colonel.
He then went to Melilla in
Morocco where he defended the fort.
I just want to show this fort.
He was a great a drawer, so he
would draw perfectly the forts --
all the Spanish forts and this
is why his memories were kept
for so long because he had so
much confidential information
of Spanish forts, fights
and military points.
These are his drawings and he
would always have a map or a card
with him to know where he was.
He would always analyze
the political,
the economic situation and so forth.
So this is a drawing by Francisco
de Miranda at age 28 of the fort
that he helped to define in Melilla.
Then he's going to go to -- this
is what gets him into problems.
That was the sort of
literature I showed you before.
This is going to be the first
time he is going to be imprisoned
because he was reading books that
were forbidden by the inquisition.
So, at that time, he really starts
developing a very radical idea
of what should be allowed and not
allowed and he starts thinking
that inquisition is not
something very fair.
It's a system of oppression and that
it's a system that is helping people
from the American continent
to develop.
I mean he believes that
ignorance is the worst enemy
of a culture unless you want
to keep people under control.
So this is the prison where he
was first imprisoned in 1879
and then colonel from America
[inaudible] is the government
who is going to take him, who
becomes later the government
of Cuba, is going to enroll in the
battalion, the battalion de Aragon
and that's where Miranda
is going to get a lot
of attention military-wise.
He was the aide Bernando de Gálvez,
who was the governor of Louisiana.
He spoke many languages.
He spoke English.
He spoke French.
He spoke Spanish.
He read Greek and Latin
and he's better prepared
than any other Spanish
soldier but he is a criollo.
He was born in America so
that is a problematic issue
for the [inaudible]
monarchy within the Army.
So the uncle of Bernando de
Gálvez, who is the Jose de Gálvez,
was the president of El Consejo de
Indias [phonetic], starts looking
after Miranda and getting
very jealous of this person,
who is getting so much
recognition and so much "power."
He's not a powerful man.
Miranda is not very powerful.
He just gets some merits and
he negotiates [inaudible]
for the English and
he wants to providence
and fought some great battles
and brought a lot of drawings
and military strategies
but he is a Caraqueño,
we were Hispano-American.
So [inaudible] begin a chase and
actually when he comes to the U.S.,
he goes to Salem and kind
of makes some comparisons
about the inquisition in the
Spanish crown how they are chasing
as if he was sort of witch
or something like that.
So that's what happens.
He gets all these accusations of
which he is going only be able
to claim his name 10 years later
in 1793, but by that point,
Miranda has already left the
Army because he knows if he goes
to prison at that time, he knows
perfectly that he will not be able
to carry on his project for
independence for South America.
So he will be commissioned
in the secret complicity
of the [inaudible], leaves Cuba
to come to the United States
and he comes with some very elegant
letters from, el gobernador de Cuba,
the Cuba government and was
able to introduce himself still
as a Spanish Army colonel.
That was really the strategy
that [inaudible] Miranda used was
to gain some time because
they were ahead of time.
When the news came that
Miranda had left the Army,
people already opened
the doors to Miranda.
People had already received
as a Spanish colonel.
So he was playing a little
bit with the issue of time
of consuming his own destiny,
which, at that time in 1783,
had already been chosen by him.
He already chose to free
America from oppression yet,
he still wanted to serve the king.
So Miranda had this duality in him.
He can't make this radical --
this radical rupture with Spain.
Spain is still the
mother, la madre patria
and the king is still la patria.
So there are a lot of concepts that
you may see that I'm presenting
to you that are defining what
the patria, the homeland,
was and who to serve
and why to serve.
Miranda is always going through
these dualistic, very complex,
reflection and very
contradictory as well.
He is a revolutionist but he
is after the French Revolution,
he becomes against revolution.
So his soldier of Spain, serving
the king, but then he wants
to be a soldier of America and
then for him, it's almost natural
that the king of Spain that the
colonists are able to manage
and to [inaudible] themselves.
He thinks it's natural.
I mean it's natural.
We've come to a certain maturity.
We have so many wealth.
We have so much education
in us, we can rule ourselves
and he thinks he is going
to convince the king.
So he keeps asking
[inaudible] to the king.
He sends this letter to Florida
Blanca, who was his minister.
He sends letters to
all of ambassadors,
the Spanish [inaudible], "please
allow me to explain my plan.
Please, let me tell how this will
be the greatest plan for America."
So he's always between this fine
line of betraying what, for him,
was his homeland and his king and
yet serving this new territory
that he sees can be so rich
and so full of treasures
and beautiful things for
the rest of the world.
So this is when he leaves.
Now, we see a portrait
of young Miranda
and he arrives in Baltimore in 1782.
At that age is when his real mission
begins, as a savior of America.
So when he comes to the U.S., this
is the trip he's going to make --
this is a very nice quote.
He attends a bar-b-que.
This is a light concept, bar-b-que.
He writes it.
he writes where the
word comes, "bar-b-que."
He says, "To end the
party at around 1:00 p.m.,
they prepare a bar-b-que."
He defines it.
"That is grilled pork with rum,
which was shared normally among the
magistrates and the well educated
and the poorest people of
the country, shaking hands
and drinking from the same glass.
It is impossible to conceive
without having witnessed it,
a truly democratic
assembly and which comes
to complete the many reunions
that were told and described
by the great poets and historians
and which took place in some
of the free villages of
Greece of their own time."
So here we find evidence
of Francisco de Miranda's
intellectual formation
and education.
He's a classical man.
He believes that Greece is the
most beautiful model of democracy.
Greece is the only place where
he is going to purchase a house.
For him, democracy is the system
to go for and it is the system
that could be put in
place in South America.
What he witnesses here is
something that he, later on,
he quotes this the same day.
He's going to say, "I will never be
able to see these in South America
because they're such a colonel
monarchy that it will be impossible
to see the magistrate having coffee
or drinking tea or
wine with a pagan."
So he is very propelled by
this society and he starts --
obviously, he visits the Congress
in Philadelphia and, as I said,
he went to New York and he
also admired Fort [inaudible]
where Washington led his battles.
He met George Washington.
He met him and he made a
quote, which is a commentary,
which is kind of interesting.
"He complimented much.
He is continuous, he's
careful, rather silent
and not very expressive, although
his kind manners make him a
terrible mind."
That is the sort of comments,
every single person he met,
he wrote something about.
He met everyone.
I met Washington, Hamilton, Sam
Addams, John Adams, Jefferson, Knox.
He was friends with
Knox, with Monroe.
He was friends with --
he traveled with Smith.
He met the king of Prussia --
William Pitt, the father of the
Lee Young, all the ambassadors
and every time, he would
leave something about it.
When Catherine the Great took
him through him her collections
of [inaudible], she opened it just
for him and before he left Russia,
she gave a dinner for him
and she gave him a passport.
She said, "Here's your passport.
Go and travel through Scandinavia.
He went and traveled form embassy to
embassy, Russian Embassy; otherwise,
the Spanish crown would
have imprisoned
because the Spanish
crown already knew
that he had this project
to liberate America.
So he was very much protected.
In this photo, you will
find 50 biographies of 50
of the most important he met.
It's very educational and all the
libraries that he has followed.
So when he comes to England, there
is an article that is published
at that time -- again, we are
in 1783 when he gets to London
and this is something that
says about the Spanish America.
A portrait -- It's a translation
from English to the French.
It's a portrait of Miranda and
it says already that there is one
of the most cultivated man in
London, trying to negotiate
to liberate the America to
the South American colony.
Everybody knows that is
what he is trying to do
because he's not very discreet.
He is a person who
arrives to the dinners
and to all these great
glamourous parties
and he will start talking
about politics.
He would start talking about
the importance of freedom
and then he would start talking
about how people should
go with him and for him.
So that's pretty much it.
as far as the life of Miranda, you
can find it on this application.
I'm just going to show -- the
French Revolution is very,
very dense because he obviously
played a great role in France.
He represented for two
years the greatest general
because he always stood for freedom
and he would always say
aloud the French [inaudible],
which the [foreign
language] "until death,"
and that was what people believed at
that time for freedom and Miranda,
in any society whether it was
the United States or the Spanish,
or some very compelling letters
from his enemies like people
in the Spanish crown at the
ministers or the ambassadors
who were looking after him
that would also define Miranda
on the greatest and they would
say, "It's too bad we lost him."
And they would say just a man like
him could go and start the movement.
They knew it was like a domino
effect and that's why Miranda,
in spite of the protection that
he had from Catherine the Great,
that's why he joined the French
Revolution because he knew
that if the French would come
to barracks in the Peninsula,
that then the colonies
would be left on their own
and they would have some space
to start emancipating themselves,
and that's actually what happened
and that's actually what he's going
to write in his journal,
"El Columbiano."
He's going to tell -- this is
published in 1810 and he's going
to actually say all that is going
on in Spain and so, again, 1810,
his journal is called,
"El Columbiano."
His journal was published
thanks to the support
of a very wealthy Spanish
family [inaudible]
and they financed his published --
his publication as well as
his translation of the letters
to the Americanos -- of the South
Americanos, [inaudible] Guzman.
He was a Peruvian Jesuit that
Miranda will very much use
as a means of trying
to justify his actions.
So he will always looking into
writings or some authors prior
to him in order to find some
intellectual basis for his actions.
This is how all the
Muslims of the frontiers
and how America started
switching and changing.
This is when he got back
here to the Americas.
He was already 60 years old.
This is the first constitution
signed
and so he was part
of that too, 1811.
This is when he is captured.
He was captured -- his last
writings, a complaining letter
to the king again in 1813 asking him
to complying with the capitalization
that had been made -- la
capitulación de San Mateo,
which was not respected and he was
yet imprisoned and sent to jail
without the right to defend himself.
So that is his last letter.
His last document is in 1813.
This is the place --
this is the prison,
la prison de las Cuatro Torres
and Arsenal de las Caracas.
This is where he died.
And he is now buried
in this cemetery right
here in a common grave.
Arsenal de las Caracas
in San Fernando,
which is like 10 km from Cadíz.
[Inaudible] But he
got imprisoned there.
[ Inaudible ]
No, they haven't found --
his body hasn't been found
and they found ADN test but, no,
there is no trace of his remains.
So he is still buried
there and his -- yeah.
His grave is empty.
There is no grave of him anywhere.
[ Inaudible ]
It is. It is but I mean what
happened was he had his own grave
in the cemetery of the arsenal
but, at one point in the middle
of 19th century, they had
to relocate the cemetery
and they sent a notice for the
family to come and take the bodies
or [inaudible] but
nobody answered for him.
So all the bodies that
were not reclaimed were put
in a common grave.
Nobody --
I think they are -- actually he had
two boys, Alejandro and Francisco.
Alejandro died very young
as a general as well.
He is buried in la
Pere Lachaise in France
and Francisco is the second one,
he married a Columbian woman
and he also died in the
war, the Independence War.
So I think I'm going
to stop right now.
I think I've said enough
about Francisco de Miranda.
I would be glad to answer
to some of your questions
or to share some of your thoughts.
>> Was he ever trialed?
>> Claudia Isabel Navas: Trial
-- like did he go to trial?
>> Yeah.
>> Claudia Isabel Navas:
After the San Mateo rendition?
No. It was -- legally, it was a
transgression of the rendition.
It was absolutely a transgression
and he was a military
of very high rank.
He was treated as a criminal
-- as a street criminal.
He was chained.
He was left in the prison in
Caracas with other criminals
and then he was sent to Puerto Rico.
The governor of Puerto Rico
admired Miranda, as I said,
even his enemies admired him.
I mean they respected him.
They knew what kind of man he was --
all the battles that he had been to,
so he really advocated for a better
treatment of General Miranda.
That's why he asked the crown
to send him to the arsenal
but the crown obviously the tower
-- I don't know if you saw that --
At the tower, there's no possibility
of escaping or -- it's right here.
It's surrounded by water, so there's
no way of escaping and he writes
in 1814 when Ferdinand the
VII comes back to the throne,
he liberates all political
prisoners except Miranda --
except Miranda and Miranda writes a
letter again to the courts of Spain
and said, "Listen, give me at
least a chance to defend myself"
because he was a very good lawyer --
empirical lawyer but a good lawyer.
He had defended himself
against the French Revolution
in [inaudible] and he had won.
People in France had taken out
of the court and he had said
"Viva la regime de Miranda.
Viva la republique."
So Miranda was a very good
spokesman, so he requested
and he knew he had the legal
right to defend himself
and the courts answered
to him saying
that they had lost his expedient.
Losing the expedient of Francisco
de Miranda was very difficult
because it wasn't this thin.
I mean Francisco de Miranda had
so many warnings to be arrested
and so many letters that they sent
that his expedient must have been
one of the most thick of all.
[ Inaudible ]
It's very interesting
because Miranda,
after the French Revolution -- I'm
going to go back a little here --
after the French Revolution, he went
to England because -- obviously --
I say obviously because
Napoleon Bonaparte didn't
like to have any rivals around him.
So obviously that excluded
of the French Army
and the French government, Miranda
didn't see any fit for his stance
with the French government,
although he had fought for France
and he believed it was
his second homeland.
He decides to go back to England
because he knew William
Pitt de Young.
So he gets back to London and in
London, he had a very good friend,
which is Turnwell [phonetic].
Turnwell is a banker.
He's always is going
to finance Miranda.
When Miranda is in this prison
in the Arsenal de la Caracas,
Turnwell is the person who
is going to still believe
in helping Miranda
escape from the prison.
I mean he's 65 years old.
So Turnwell -- they had
this plan -- I don't know.
They were going to escape
through a window or whatever
and Miranda died before
the plan got to fit
but Turnwell helped
Miranda go back to England
and Miranda knows Ambassador
Rufus King,
who is their English ambassador
in France and so he goes back
with great letters again.
He always manages even
after revolutions --
he always managed to get a
good recommendation letter
and he goes back and sets
a house with all his books.
He's got more than 5000
books and opens his house
to all his fellow Americans -- young
Hispanic Americans were looking
to fight for independence
of the colonies
and so there come Simon
Bolivar, Palacios, [inaudible],
Pedro Fermín de Vargas,
Bernando Higgins, San Martin came
when Miranda had already left
with Bolivar, Andres Bello,
[inaudible] -- I mean there are all
these young generation, you know,
that come from the Americas
and even from Mexico that stay
with Miranda in Miranda's house.
So, yeah, the relationship
with Bolivar is very close.
The father of Bolivar had
called upon Miranda in 1797
and they were trying to make him
work for this independence plan.
So the Bolivar family and
Miranda knew each other already
and that's how they
came to work together.
Bolivar and Higgins are the
biggest disciples of Miranda.
[ Inaudible ]
Miranda? Okay, he was
in London in 1791 first.
He met there a great man from
France called Telihon [phonetic],
who was a very, very wise and very,
tricky, tricky bullet politician --
he told Miranda -- he heard
Miranda in one of these dinners
because Miranda had
a very mundane life.
He went to theaters and he went to
dinners, and he saw so many women
and had such a social life,
very, very eclectic social life
and Telihon heard him talk about
his plans to emancipate America
and he said, "You know what?
You should go to plans
because there are some plans."
Telihon obviously knew
everything that was going
in the clubs during the
revolutionary area and so he goes
from London to Paris and
he's trying to go to Russia
to see Catherine the Great
and he arrives to Paris
with recommendation letters from
Telihon to meet with the mayor, who,
at that time, [inaudible]
was [foreign language].
They're going to be fascinated
by the personality of Miranda,
by his experience, by his knowledge,
the fact that he won here some
battles, that he was protected
by Catherine the Great,
and this is spring 1792.
He spends all the summer there
and the destiny made it happen
that the Duke of Brunswick
threatens the French
and the French people react,
and there's the famous speech
of [inaudible] who is going to
say the armies [foreign language]
"Our patriot is in danger," and so
it's the call of the [inaudible].
It's the moment where the king, the
queen and the royal family is going
to be imprisoned, all the frontiers
are closed, and Miranda is there
by chance, by an accident of
life, by his revolutionary life,
destiny that he had
inscribed in his.
[ Inaudible ]
Exactly. Exactly, absolutely.
This is why it's so interesting
we're celebrating Columbus Day
and actually Miranda will admire
very much Christopher Columbus,
although he will criticize
the level of conquest,
the privilege of the
right of conquest.
So this is the ambivalence
of Miranda.
He will write so much based
on the [foreign language].
That's his bible.
Vatel [phonetic] is his bible.
It's like he knows every single
civilization to be or not
to be conquered and he
will criticize of conquest
but he will admire
Christopher Columbus
and he will never ever
revoke him the fact
of having created this America.
It's very beautiful.
In a way, again, it's part
of his imaginary of trying
to develop a new homeland.
It's also something
that is in the air --
like everything that was in his
life, something that he will pick
that he will pick on and then he
will put onto paper and, as I said,
Columbia was already used in
New York to change the name
of Kings College, so
it's Columbia University,
so Miranda might have
just gotten inspired.
[ Inaudible ]
What's particular about
all of this is
that Christopher Columbus was
also buried somewhere else and at
that time had been
somewhat forgotten.
[ Inaudible ]
[ Applause ]